>> I started watching the video. I heard I heard then the
Mormon police are trying to cover it up and I was like, "Okay."
>> I will say they seem to have abused abuse their power
a little bit. Like the raid seemed totally uncalled for. I don't know
if you thought most. >> Yes. The police are going to have
to >> We're like comparing it We're like comparing it to
you're like importing some Chud like watching black people get
shot moments right here. But I'm saying
so the truth value is not what the story has been. >> So
the truth value of the claim, how can it be changed by the information
being subsequent? How does that make sense?
[music] Blax's coverage of that Lego story is his worst yet.
Is it though? I saw a clip from Queman and Queman was basically
just wrong, I think.
And you know, I don't want to defend Willie Mack, but I think
Queman, from what I saw in the clip, can I can I watch it again?
Now, I I don't doubt that Willie Max said some really. Okay,
I have zero doubt that he said that, but I watched this this
Clement bit on
where is this? Can I find it? Him covering the Lego stuff. >> I
hear Willie's been doing research by watching Legal Mindset lately.
>> This story has gone from a YouTuber trying to retrieve
an old man's Lego collection that was stolen by a bricks and
minifigs franchise into revealing >> wrong what seems to
be.
>> This story has been, but that's the story. Reckless
Ben was telling
wrong at that statement. >> I hear Willie's been doing
research by watching Legal Mindset lately.
>> This story has gone from a YouTuber trying to retreat.
>> This story has gone from this is like the story that
was presented.
So I actually just think Queen is like totally wrong calling
that out.
I'm sure Willie says a bunch of other really that made Quan like
ready to hop off the porch here
that I'm unaware of. But just that first wrong I'm like no that
is an old Lego collection that was stolen by a bricks and minifigs
franchise into revealing >> wrong what seems to be a Mormon
mafia
>> it stated as fact the story has been this this story
has been that's the story that was getting told that's what was
going around the internet right yeah yeah I have no doubt that
he's saying what's what Ben's presented as the story
I have no doubt about that now if he say if he goes on and I'm
guessing the rest of the coverage is like this and that's probably
why we were ready to hop off the porch already. But if I were
Willy Mack, I would have been ready to call this out. I would
have quoted this and gone, "Hey, I said what the story was so
far." Anyway, I have only seen the clip. I haven't seen all the
coverage, so I have no idea. >> Dude, crazy. So immediately
wrong. There was not $2,000 worth of Lego stolen by. >> Also,
it's it's not 200,000. Massive error from Queen again.
>> That did not happen. >> [__] up. gone
from a YouTuber trying to retrieve an old man's Lego collection
that was stolen by a bricks and minigs franchise into revealing
what seems to be a Mormon mafia
>> seems to be seems to be seems to be >> covering
for the store >> so it was not $2,000 stolen and I think
William is going to misattribute
uh who likely stole it so let's see >> the police continually
into revealing what seems to be a Mormon mafia covering for the
store owner the police >> total just insane cap schizophrenic
conspiracy theory. >> The 200,000. Yeah, I said wrong.
Smaggle. Smaggle. You think you think you can get me there? I
said Willie was wrong. I didn't say Willie lied about the $200,000.
Now Ben lied about the
>> I agree with that. That it's saying somebody lied and
is wrong is different.
>> Ben lied about the $200,000, but people accepted that
without substantiation.
Willie Mack, top researcher and commentary. I've been hearing
makes the best entry videos for normal guys cuz he's a normal
guy himself. Did not do his due diligence and just accepted some
claim in some stupid YouTube video from some stupid prank YouTuber.
>> Yeah,
but he is talking about like what the story has been. I I feel
like this is accurate when you're going over like what people
understand the Lego story to be about. Now, I'm guessing Willy
Mack doesn't circle back around and say, "Oh, well, actually,
this is what really happened here. I I get it. I get why you're
mad. It's fine." Yeah. Yeah. I I get why you're mad. I do get
why you're mad. It's fine.
Respond to the point that Willie Max's an illiterate
like yokal.
I mean, I agree with that. I agree that he's incapable of doing
research. I agree that he's a total
>> Why is it acceptable to repeat claims simply because
a YouTube video has said them? He's He's couching the claim and
saying this is what the story's been. So I'm saying he doesn't
just couch out the video. He doesn't just couch out the >> I
know. That's why I'm saying when you >> So I'm reading
I'm reading the statement correctly because I know what he says
in the video.
>> Well, you pre-watched the video. Okay. I'm just saying
in a reaction you wouldn't know that. So you like paused. >> If
I was blind reacting if I was blind reacting and just had no
idea what Willie Max said in the video. Yeah. I wouldn't know
and I'd be wrong. But I'm not wrong cuz I know what Willie Max
is in the video and that is what he's >> Okay. I'm saying
it's not wrong up to that point. So Smagago could have actually
wiped you if he had just said, "Well, how do you know it's wrong?
>> Actually, just how do you know he's not going to say
something different in the video?" And I say, "Well, because
I know what Willy Max is in the video because I know his position
on this."
>> But I I'm just saying if you're trying to make like
daily commentary slop and you're reacting to what people are
saying and trying to address it on what basically knowing that
they'll be totally if they're lying about it, which Ben is now,
>> but that's not that's not what Willy M claims to do.
That's not what Willie M does. That's not >> Yeah, he's
No, >> that's that's not an acceptable thing to do to be
honest. It's not acceptable to just unless you literally say
this YouTuber is claim and you hedge everything with this YouTuber
is claiming this. This is an allegation. That's not what that's
not what happens here. It's not really >> the story has
gone from this to what seems to be this seems like it is
that is like in the simply the the technical language sense that
is hedged, but if you know what he elaborates with, it's not
it doesn't really matter.
Well, I wouldn't subject myself to watching a Willie Mesh
this guy's alleged it's allegedly this guy's a
and then you you go in throughout the entire video to state as
fact a bunch of evidence and arguments that support them being
a
that they're all easily picked apart. >> But up until this
point, it's like hedged and I would say, "Oh, you better better
be able to substantiate that."
>> Okay. So, but you said I was wrong. >> Yeah. Up
until that point in the video when this is just the intro. That
is wrong. Like, you can't say that based on the information presented.
So, you're arguing with the audience already about why they're
wrong for calling you out for something. >> Okay. So, what
am I wrong about? Wait, what am I wrong about? >> You didn't
lie.
>> You can't determine it from the information that's been
presented so far. But you can determine if you've got the rest
of the information.
>> You can determine if you've got the rest of the information,
but I don't know what the point is.
>> How am I wrong if I've got the rest of the information?
>> You're like literally doing a reaction to six sense
and you start with, "Well, actually, this makes sense because
this guy's been dead the whole time." >> Yeah, you'd be
correct. >> I don't know what the exercise is. Yeah, I
don't know what the I don't know what the exercise is.
>> Yeah. It's not a very good
uh uh audience. You're you're you're by the way, you're saying
wrong in the strict language sense. In the strict language sense,
just to be clear, in the strict language sense, you are wrong.
You already admitted it was hedged. So when you say it's wrong,
when it's a hedge statement, you are wrong. >> You're just
basically saying, well, this is wrong based on me knowing what's
going on later. >> No. So if I say when I say this guy
is
>> and I repeat with substantiations for that that are
lies or incorrect arguments. The idea that I'm not wrong in my
repeated stating of allegedly this guy's a simply because I put
an allegedly or an attribution uh when I'm clearly supporting
the allegation repeatedly. That's no you're you're stating that
as a claim at that point. >> I think that could be So here's
the problem I have. I think there's something weaker to that
when it's like the level of viral that this story was.
I do think there's something weaker to that because he >> just
like being like a total sheep to just believe some viral video.
I felt like doing >> No, I think I think he could totally
be torn apart for this after the fact. But I'm saying that up
until this point in the video with the couch language, it's not
wrong. It's actually not strictly wrong. It's based on some other
information. Like it's based on some information that you're
not even revealing at the time. >> What? The rest of the
video? Yeah, >> I am. What do you mean? So, >> you're
saying this is wrong, right? But you've watched the rest of the
video, but you don't say this is wrong. I've seen where he goes
with this. He's going to stack up a bunch of claims. This is
wrong. I would say if you want to say somebody's wrong, you should
probably explain why they're wrong. No, >> because he's
he's introduc Well, he's introducing the claim. That's the first
time he introduced the claim. That's why I'm saying it's it's
wrong.
>> Okay. He's introducing the claim. The story so far has
been >> he's introducing the claim. He's then going to
argue for throughout the video. >> Yes. But you don't know
that yet. That's why I'm saying >> I do know he's for that
claim. But I do know he's going for that claim. >> But
you don't present that to the >> Okay. That that doesn't
make me wrong. Means I didn't show working, right? Like it's
[clears throat] like the difference
saying, you know,
oh 5* 5 isn't 25 or saying you didn't write it out. You know,
>> I'm just saying that up until that point in the video
with what's with with what's laid out there, you're saying wrong.
There's no way for anybody like if somebody's going to argue
against you based on not having that information like you're
just saying wrong if if you're making that video for the first
time, right? If you're producing that as a segment, >> I'm
not producing as a segment. I'm not doing that as a convincing
thing. I was doing this as a tail end of the stream to talk about
how I hate Willie Mack.
>> That's fair
to me. >> To me, you don't have that information yet according
to like what I'm seeing there. So, you're saying wrong, but it's
not like there's a bunch of other going on, right? So, I can't
identify that the rest of the video is about that being stacked
up. I think he is hedging at the beginning of the video. And
so, you could say after after a while when I'm guessing he presents
some evidence and he says, "So, this story is correct." Or something
along these lines, then you can go and say, "Okay, now I can
say you're wrong." But the hedge statement at the beginning,
I just don't think is is wrong. I think >> Yeah, he he
does repeatedly say he like just makes repeated false claims
and says that this guy's aditting admitted to stealing the Legos
and all this. So, I mean, he does repeatedly just state that.
[clears throat]
I believe you completely I'm tell I'm telling you I'm telling
you that he is claiming that to be true. I'm telling you that
when he says the story is that's what he is claiming to be true.
So when I say wrong to that statement I'm saying that because
I know Willie Mac is claiming that to be true in the video and
that is a wrong a wrong claim. >> So if you're including
information that isn't apparent to the audience I'm going to
say wrong unless you say because I know this from later in the
video.
>> You're saying wrong. Okay, but I did say that and you're
still saying that I was wrong. But it seems like I was wrong.
>> The read I get from the clip right here >> is
that you're watching this, right? You go to this, you you go
pull this up and you say wrong immediately on this claim. That's
what you're saying wrong to. And then you're saying, well, there's
some hidden information here, which is why I watched the whole
video and I know his position. So, I'm actually responding to
the position that isn't this one. I'm not responding to this
couch position. I'm responding to his actual position that he
lays out later that is the same as his couch position, but just
less not couched anymore. I'm like, "Okay, well, I I don't see
why that's related." >> Well, like I say, I mean, you can
say that that's like bad form for presentation information. I
agree. I wasn't trying to present the information well. Um, but
I don't understand what I was wrong about. >> Well, just
in terms of right here, what I see is a couch claim that he can't
be wrong about. He's saying what this what the story has been
so far and then seems to be the case that there's some cult in
the police or whatever. Right? And I would agree that if he then
went on, which I have not seen yet, which is not a part of this,
right? I didn't say to to the Mormon police thing. I said that's
just I said it was a schizophrenic conspiracy theory. I didn't
I didn't say that Willie Mack was claiming that as a fact in
the same way that saying wrong implies that they're claiming
it as a fact. Obviously that part Yeah. Willie Mack is Will does
like a double hedge. He adds another hedge >> Okay. Sure.
It's uh I again I think I've laid out my position on this why
I think what I do. I think it's just like it's just not it's
not clear to me at all. And so I'm going to go like oh wrong
based on this clip. But you've laid out that you're saying okay
well I actually know his position for later. You don't say that.
I'm going to say that when you say wrong to the couch position
that is wrong. You can come in and say okay okay sure but was
I was I actually wrong
>> about him later laying that out as a more concrete position
that he believes.
>> Yeah. But is it is if let's say someone says as a cuz
this what is determines whether I'm whether I'm wrong here. I
feel like is if someone says as a claim something like allegedly
or the story is and then they give an allegation and then they
repeatedly argue for that allegation and repeatedly make claims
that um determine >> like 100% >> it's not wrong
until they do the second
>> What? Okay. But if you know that's what they're doing.
If you know that's what they're doing in the in the video, that
doesn't matter, does it? >> I think it does matter. >> If
Okay, how how does that possible? I think it does matter. If
you have full information and you make a statement of full information
to it, >> no, it it doesn't matter to whether it's a true
or false claim. Judience,
I can I can find an analogy for this. Hold on. I can find an
analogy for this. >> That can't possibly change it, JTO.
That cannot that
sense. Somebody says the sky is blue, but actually what you don't
realize is that 99% of people don't see color correctly. And
color blind people are like actually well this wouldn't work
with color blind people, but like there's some unknown information
later that makes you realize that that's false. And when somebody
says the sky is blue without any of that information being revealed
to your audience, you just say >> someone's never been
outside. There's a purple screen on the windows and so they see
outside and they see it as purple. They've never been outside
the sky. I say the sky is blue, the sky is blue. And they're
saying no, the sky is purple. The sky is purple. But they can't
know cuz they they haven't seen outside the house ever. And then
they go outside the house and they see the sky is blue. I wasn't
wrong for telling them the sky is blue. I knew the sky didn't
part. Sorry. He hedged. So the story has been so far what everybody
believes is the sky is blue. >> I'm I see the sky is blue.
I'm seeing that the sky is blue. I'm seeing that the sky is blue.
I'm sorry. Now I'm seeing that the sky is purple. I'm seeing
the sky is purple. >> No. What the story has been what
people believe is that the sky is blue. That's not wrong. >> I
don't understand how that's different to what I said. You're
saying I the I You're giving You're giving the
>> The story has Do you can you believe that the story
has the sky as purple? I see the sky as perception of purple.
Here you go. Here you go. Here you go. I see the sky as >> Everybody
sees the sky as purple. >> Everybody sees the sky as purple.
>> Okay. So, someone says everybody sees the sky as purple.
And I say wrong. >> But every you already acknowledged
in this that everybody sees the sky as >> Yeah. The the
person I'm talking to sees the sky as purple cuz they've never
seen they've never left. Everybody else sees the sky as purple
as well. The story has been this broadly believed narrative has
been this. You cannot >> We're limited to one person. We're
limited to one person this analogy because it's just it I don't
see it. >> But I don't want it to be limited to one person
because he's talking about a >> how how does the mass change
it? How does the mass change it? >> Explain how that mass
change it because the mass the mass believes the wrong
>> And so when he says the story is banned as in the mass
believes the wrong thing, >> that person believes the wrong
thing. that person believes the wrong thing.
>> Okay. But they're not wrong about what >> they're
not He's not saying that >> they're correct.
>> Yeah. They're not wrong about what they see either.
That's what that's part of the analogy. So that's how the analogy
>> Okay. So you're Okay, fine. You're saying he's saying
I see this guy as purple. Sure. And you go wrong. But he does
see this guy is purple. Yeah. >> Wrong. He's correct.
>> Okay. This this has to require that
given the information, the perception would change. Well, I mean,
yeah, but you you have the information or you have the idea that
he goes on
So, it's required. So, if you So, the issue with that now is
that if you say I see I see it as
that can still be true
as you're claiming it
um in that it with the new information. However, in this case,
we both surely agree that if you say allegedly with a with a
serious allegation, with an actual allegation or something, and
then you repeatedly justify it with false uh uh arguments or
evidence that lead to it being 100%
>> um that that cannot you it's it's a cop out to say that's
not a wrong statement. But I don't understand how you can say
that the information being subsequent in the video
alters whether that statement is wrong or not. >> So you're
arguing that he is trying to do like a sort of like a thing where
a Candace Owens where he's trying to hedge he did a video on
Candace Owens where he's trying to say like >> he doesn't
he's not trying to No, no, no, no, no, no. He's not even try.
He's not trying to. if Willie Mac is just like stating that he's
just like he if he was making
this this video in a way that was
like actually um debunking this he wouldn't there's no way in
hell he would play out his full intro just stating this is as
a case. Can you imagine? >> I think I think the video is
better that way. Like I I do think that would be an opening for
a video where you could go the opposite. would introduce actual
doubt. You would introduce actual doubt. But this is very clearly
played as what the what the story is going to be. Not just what
the story has been, what the story is going to be. The story
you're going to be told by this video. >> Not when you
say not when you say wrong. >> Not when you say wrong.
>> Unless it literally immediately changes after that.
>> But I know it doesn't. >> Yeah. But that would
be a good answer. >> But I know it doesn't. >> I
know you know it doesn't. But I'm >> so but so the truth
value but what the story has been. >> So the truth value
of the claim how can it be changed by the information being subsequent.
How does that make sense?
>> I'm not making I'm not making a statement on the point
at which the information appears in the video. I'm making a statement
on the validity of the claim having evaluated the evidence and
we both agree that if you make that claim in that way and then
you
>> okay I would agree with that but you haven't seen the
substantiation and that claim is not real. the the underlying
fact is wrong. So unless you're arguing that he's trying to do
the Candace Owens thing where he is saying like well
that allegedly is only because he doesn't want to substantiate
it truly. He doesn't want to actually do any due >> He's
not even trying to do that. He's literally not even trying to
do that. He's just like introing the video and he just states
it as fact repeatedly in the
He's literally not even there's not even an attempt at hedging.
He the idea that we're even arguing this is hedging. He's not
even attempting to hedging. This is just like a quirk of the
way that he's introduced it in the video because he liter just
uncritically repeats this conclusion repeatedly.
>> Okay. And I agree that that's probably bad once he started
doing that. But again, it's just the the >> Okay. But how
does the truth of that statement change based on the order of
the information? That doesn't make any sense.
If you know that the rest of the information is in the video,
if you know the rest of the video is that way, how can it change?
How can how can you be wrong say that statement is wrong?
>> Oh, because it doesn't change. He the story is still
that $200,000 in Lego. I'm sure that I'm sure that's still the
story. That is true statement. >> But this is okay. Allegedly,
this person is this is I just bring it back to this analogy.
We both agree that it would be a total copout to say, "Oh, I'm
not wrong. I'm not wrong. If you've substantiated the allegedly
with a bunch of conclusions that you state as fact, you can't
you can't go I'm not wrong. I'm not wrong after saying I say
allegedly. I allegedly
>> in this case he's saying the story has been and I just
think that is a factual claim. That is the what the story has
been. He's literally >> Yeah. Allegedly. Allegedly.
>> Is that the same as allegedly? >> Yes. The story
has been your >> I'm trying to think if there's a difference.
The story has been Yeah. But you understand that that is still
a like unfortunately for Destiny the story has been the story.
If I say the story has been Destiny's a he behind Arby's last
>> Yeah. The first claim that would not be false. The second
claim could be >> No. No. >> Well, they're both falsifiable
>> because I'm not referring in that instance. I'm not
referring to any actual story about that might accuse. This requires
it being a fresh story, not a pre-existing perception that isn't
that isn't tied to the story being covered, right? Obviously,
yes, you could you can latch on. So, it would be like you take
some take some different Nicholas Doro is a he behind Arby's
last
Likely story to be honest. He behind Arby's last week. >> Mhm.
Uh um Nicholas has been binn he's a if I'm I'm stating as as
fact the idea that he behind Arby's last week you know that that
that's to it's totally for me to then turn around and go I'm
not wrong I'm not wrong about the the story has been that he's
a
if I if that's if that's the video I make that would be to [__]
how that response >> on his face is not wrong. So when
you say wrong, you're wrong. But you're saying you what you would
point out is that he is trying to create this like doubt or trying
to like say something in a way that doesn't require or that absolves
him of having a position while repeatedly substantiating that
position. Well, repeatedly taking that position. So he's being
dishonest, but it's not wrong. It's a factually correct statement.
You've already admitted >> Yeah. I said linguistically
it is hedged but it's it's
>> it a way that is accurate I don't think that matters
>> that Ben had a massively viral story >> but that
is the same thing with the statement but it would be total to
>> well but it would have to be something people broadly
believe right that would have had to be the story and I think
you can say that as the person covering the reckless Ben thing
in a way that well with Nicholas being a that wouldn't be the
case but with destiny you could >> you could say the sto
that the story has been If you were then going to go on to take
a critical eye to the story, but if you just repeat the allegations
then through your own voice as your own allegations that you
say it was dishonest of you to say it that way, but it doesn't
make it factually incorrect.
>> You are dishonestly framing that factual statement to
like go towards your own ends to present it as though
make yourself seem like you're actually looking.
I think you're correct in that he is being dishonest in a way
that makes it seem like he's going to try to be critical when
he has no intention of being. And so that's true that I think
that's true, but it's also true that the story has been $200,000
in Legos have been stolen. >> I think it's a it's an immaterial
distinction. I think that's if you say wrong to that. I think
that's a it's totally fine to say it's wrong a wrong statement.
Someone says the story has been and you know they're substantiating
the claim. >> I would be I would be concerned if a bunch
of people clapped along with that for you. No.
without you substantiating why you think
>> No, because I think they're hearing I think they're
hearing it the same way because I I've told them that that's
what the video is about.
>> Bro, that's Have you watched this? Dude, I watched it
out of order and it's actually his second video is really well
edited to make it seem like he's correct. Like I can see where
he might where there might be like holes in what he's saying.
The second video is so much better than the first video. I watched
it second video first. I'm like, "Holy, this guy's getting totally
like for no reason." Then I watch the first video and it's like,
"Oh
no, there's a lot of holes here." Did you watch these videos?
>> I watched I haven't I didn't watch them in order. I
don't even know if I've watched like all the Reckless Ben videos.
I've just watched um most of like the I watched the Coffeezilla
video. I watched like most of the body cams. I watched
um the first Reckless Ben video for
I uh I watched the second one by myself and then I started watching
it on stream and I watched the first one and I was like hyping
it up and then I slowly started to realize that he was like clearly
lying about things in the first one and it soured the whole reaction
for me. It just pissed me off. >> I just the moment I literally
the moment I looked at one of the reasons why I didn't cover
it, one of the thoughts I had is this is going to be like total
and it's going to take you two weeks to >> I started watching
the video. I heard I heard then the Mormon police are trying
to cover it up and I was like, "Okay,
>> They I will say they seem to have abused abused their
power a little bit. Like the raid seemed totally uncalled for.
I don't know if you thought most >> No, I watched all the
body cams through Chud and I totally agree with with Chud's assessment
of that stuff. It's just like totally once you see it all play
out, it's like okay, no, >> I think he looks psycho. I'm
saying the swatting on his house was like weird to >> It's
not SWAT. So why are we calling that swatting? Why are we calling
that >> They not have weapons. >> Well, it doesn't
matter if they have weapons. A swatting is a false call from
someone online. It's not if the police raid you because they've
got they believe you've committed a crime. >> Wrong wronging
with like their guns out and is like this stoner kid. Yeah, there
was like it was totally legit for them to raid him because um
I mean you just have to watch all the body cams, but I mean it's
just like there's a bunch of weird going on where they're all
obviously coordinating and they're going around literally harassing
the [__] out of this guy repeated to his house. There's
a 16-year-old kicking around. There's a 16-year-old kicking around
with them. It's just all like, you know, such a bizarre situation.
I totally don't blame the police for raiding it, especially after
they had so many bad interactions with them. They seem shifty
as they're just telling themselves to >> What do you mean?
Hold on. What do you mean? What do you mean you don't feel bad
for it? What are you doing right >> I'm not saying I don't
feel bad. Wait, I didn't say I didn't say feel bad. Did I say
I don't feel bad? I said I think the police totally reasonable.
I'm saying it's totally reasonable. It's totally reasonable conduct
from the police. >> What is reasonable about the raid?
>> Well, they had evidence of stalking and harassment and
they thought they were coordinating it. So, they and they were
all staying the Airbnb. >> Okay. I thought they had stolen
Legos in >> That's not why they raided. No, that's not
why they raided for the Airbnb. That's not why they raided. Is
that not in the search warrant? >> No, they they raided
because of the stalking harassment claims.
>> Wait, so you're telling me there's no nothing about
stolen Legos in the search >> I don't know if there's any
stolen Legos and search warrant. My understanding is it's not
about the the the raid is not about stolen Legos. The guy portrays
it. It's just being about stolen Legos, but it's not. It's about
the It's about the the entire case of >> the stalking and
I that I forget where you find out about them doing the duck
thing. But like they left parts of they left bits out of the
video where they >> I don't know if it's just just the
duck thing. There was like loads of they were like going over
to his neighbors and getting signs put up. They had um like this
other guy like loitering around who had this weird [__]
interaction with the police where they ask for his phone. He
complies at first and he puts it in their hand and yinks it back
out immediately and they have to arrest him that um and that
guy's like coordinated with them. pretty sure that there's like
it's just like they they have repeated instances of these bad
interactions with the same people who are obviously collaborating
and repeatedly showing up to the same guy's house and harassing
this business. They have a pretty good case just like go and
raid these guys and see what if they're coordinating at that
point if they they've had repeated
>> Can you can you tell me why that required a raid and
not just like a door knock and walking in and arresting? because
they've already had instances that what the guy they end up arresting
the guy who yinks his phone for for uh under suspicion trying
to destroy
>> which was total obviously right >> it's not no
>> you don't think that was the guy >> if you asked
for okay you asked for your phone by a place have you actually
watched that body cam or have you just seen Ben's edit
>> I've seen Ben's edit but I didn't think like it's literally
>> you should watch the body cam yeah no it's not just
a two second interaction
>> All right. So, he just totally lied about it. >> Yes,
he just lied about it. Yes. Yes. Literally. Go. Let me find Where's
the Where's the body cam? Yeah. Yeah. Where's the Where's the
body cam? >> I'll I'll find it. I know where it is in Chad's
thing. I don't have the the >> This seems like a totally
crazy thing to lie about. >> This is It is insane. No,
the lie he tells is insane. The lie he tells is >> I I
don't know what evidence could he beh It's crazy to me that he
could be deleting evidence or destroying
So you will you if you so you're asked for your phone by a police
officer
uh you're about to put it into his hand. You don't even necessarily
have to comply at that point as my understand I don't think he
was actually being forced to hand over he was he was asked give
his phone but they think it's evidence and they've had this long
conversation with him about you know uh you could show us your
phone and you could show that you're not coordinating with them.
Um and basically he agrees to hand over his phone. He puts it
in their hand as it touches the officer's hand. He yanks it back
out assumably to lock it. But all guidance that you'll be given
as a police officer is obviously going to tell you if someone
starts trying to manipulate their phone, they could be trying
to wipe it. And once you have >> So none of this Wait,
hold on. >> Once you have a No, it is like that's how I
saw it. He put it in his hand and then he pulled it back. >> He
doesn't I don't believe that's shown in the video. It's not shown
in the video. In the video, Ben makes an edit where he he doesn't
even
>> This is This is the wrong me. >> No. Okay. Um
and Lieutenant Lieutenant Adamson can correct me if I'm wrong,
but we're going to seize your phone right
>> Yeah, that is precisely edited that way in Ben's video.
>> I'm I don't think so. Wind it back.
>> I'm pretty sure it's not. >> We're going to seize
your phone right
>> Don't do not do that. >> Yeah, for sure. >> You
understand me right now? your
>> I that is pull up pull up Ben's video. >> So maybe
maybe here's what I'm thinking. >> He does not show it
going
>> is it probably like >> he takes this out. No no
no no.
>> The whole thing all all Ben shows is up until the guy
holds the phone out slightly in front of him. He doesn't show
it touching the officer's hand and he shows him trying to lock
it. He completely cuts out the any contact with the offices.
>> Okay. I I assumed he was basically touching the officer's
hand. So maybe like that's the story that they told in >> You
can you can see the the >> like the interrogation room
or whatever. >> Go look at the edit. Look at the edit.
>> We're watching right now. >> Do not do that. You
don't. Okay. >> Body cam pe Sheldon's phone. So he Sheldon
says okay and reaches in his pocket to give it to him. But at
this point, Sheldon sees that his phone is
>> Oh,
he does deceptively edit it. I thought it touched the officer's
hand. I thought I totally thought he touched his >> Totally
deceptively edit this, >> but but hold on. It's still to
me it's materially the same. It's not any different. Like, this
edit is deceptive, but it's not actually any different.
>> It's worth watching like the full police
because it's already been laid out to this guy that you can submit
this phone as evidence >> to
try and clear yourself and he has now agreed to do that basically
and now he's yinking the phone away. At that point, you are it's
obvious. It's obvious and reasonable and justified and you probably
want this to happen that an officer is going to take the phone
and try and arrest them for trying to destroy evidence because
the moment you're yoinking that phone away. Why
why take the risk? Why give the risk that they're not going to
wipe it?
Obviously, that's where the mind is first going to go, why the
where the mind first should go, where they should be trained
to go. >> Okay. And you're basically saying because of
the rest of the interaction that there's just no charity left
to give here. It just seems like >> that it's been established
that he's handing this over as evidence. It's been established
that's what's happening here. You can't be handing something
over as evidence and then start manipulating it in in ways that
the officer can't foresee.
>> Okay. Do you think he's like he pulls it away from the
guy? I bro I don't I don't think there's any reason he shouldn't
be able to like like I think probably if he's handing his phone
over locked that's not really going to count as evidence right
but there's no reason that this guy even if he has if he hasn't
handed over yet I feel no there's no reason you shouldn't be
able to lock his phone
>> yeah he he but he can lock his phone so this is this
is the difference like you can yes you can lock your phone yes
he could lock his phone what you can't do is go to is say you're
going to hand it over and then start suddenly ly manipulating
it. That's what that's what you can't do. >> obviously
they're going to take that as an indication you might be able
to destroy evidence.
>> Maybe maybe the deceptiveness.
It's deceptive.
>> Sorry. Warped in chest saying he wasn't manipulating
it. >> Your phone right now.
>> Hold on. >> That's that's just a bizarre statement.
>> So he does not have his hand on the phone. He's not
touching the screen of the phone. >> Okay. Is that a call
you're supposed to make when this guy's yinking his phone away?
manipulate to Bro, there's no way.
>> I Yeah, I I think this is reasonable. I think you if
you are handing your phone over as evidence, hand your phone
over as evidence. Don't yank it away at the last second. You're
going to get arrested. You should be arrested.
>> It's It's like, you know, let me reach my license and
registration real quick into my holster shaped wallet. You know,
like what the are we doing? >> I I guess I would have to
see what your rights are in America when you've said like, "Okay,
I'm going to I'm going to give this to you." Wait, hold on. I
need to do something. You know what I mean? To me, it see it
feels so crazy to think he's like trying to delete information
from this phone. He doesn't have his hand on the screen. He's
not touching the screen of the phone.
>> You're taking you're determining that by looking at
this one frame in the video that you've paused, not >> looking
at it front on as this guy looks at it the moment this guy starts
touching stuff.
>> literally he he sets in goes to put his hand on like
what's this guy doing? He looks at this guy like what's he doing?
And then the moment he starts >> not touching the phone,
not touching the screen of the phone. Clear line of sight. Can
see that there's no manipulation of the data on the phone. >> No
manipulation of the data on the phone. Still no manipulation
of the data on the phone. Now he's moved. >> Okay. How
do you know there's no manipulation of data on the phone? Simply
because he's not swiping. >> I Okay, so he's somebody who's
got like a secret capability built into his phone where he can
delete all data by pressing two side buttons or something. >> You
could the argument we've got. >> I mean, you can Do people
not do that? Can people not do that? that you can have phones
wipe through apps or or root kits or whatever very easily, dude.
Dude, should police officers take that
>> Come on.
>> No, seriously. Should they should police officers take
the risk someone's going to wipe evidence? >> I I think
it's absurd to think he's going to wipe evidence here. But I
understand how the totality of the interaction, depending on
how annoying these people are, might have led him to the place
where he just lost all of his charity at this point. He's just
like this guy like the second. >> This is after This is
not the first, you know, this is pretty into the story. says
the first time >> they all
one guy >> it's it's
>> you know the idea that you they're asking for the phone
as evidence the guy goes to hand it over and then suddenly starts
doing something with it. I don't know what you expect or want
to happen other than an arrest and seizure of the phone in that
situation. That's how the police should >> I fully don't
believe or understand why you'd be offering to turn it over if
you were then going to delete evidence like in front of the officer.
I just don't what like what could have even happened here? What
is the plausible way? Like he doesn't have to give his phone
over. >> No, no, he he doesn't as far as I understand.
No, but once you start giving it over, you you either need to
give it over or not. That's the thing. You can't start making
sudden movements or changing your mind about stuff or you need
to make a decision. You need to either assert your rights and
not do anything or comply and start
and probably the former to be honest. But once you start complying,
it's like you're you're like it's getting out your car and making
sudden movements and it's like what what are you doing? What
are you doing? Yes, the police are going to have to >> comparing
we're like comparing it to you're like importing some chud like
watching black people get shot moments right here.
[laughter] It's like like I swear to God you're making sudden
movements. I'm very scared. It's like no I don't I don't think
that's like a real thing we could do for a phone here. It's it's
actually crazy. No, I I think absolutely 100% if you think someone
is going to if there's a reason to believe someone is going to
destroy evidence,
you act to stop them doing it. That is a that is a totally reasonable
interpretation there is there's a good chance he's going to destroy
evidence >> when he wants his phone back away. That is
totally reasonable to suspect and act upon that suspicion. I
I don't think it's actually reasonable in any way, but I'd probably
have to watch the first like 10 minutes of the interaction to
see how he got that exasperated that he is going to try to paint
it that way. I still don't see it that way. >> I I literally
do not think it it matters. It's literally you can have that
just pure interaction, just that 5 seconds if it's been agreed
that that phone is being handed over as evidence in attempt to,
you know, whatever assu
officers care about. They just want, you know, they want him
to hand over his phone. so they can see what's going on. >> We
need some some like actual lawyer to come along and explain to
us like if you say something like that, like if you tell an officer,
"Yeah, I'm going to turn this over as evidence," and then you
go to like change something, like what is that now? Is the act
of you saying, "I'm going to turn this over as evidence." Is
that like you signing a verbal contract to the police that you're
turning this over without touching anything?
>> It's It's not whether it's a verbal contract or not.
It's that's not what I'm saying. I'm saying that he's handing
it over. He has started handing it over. If he starts doing things
with the evidence with that evidence that are you know could
have unforeseen consequences i.e. destroying it then they they
they need to act they need act not unforeseen adverse consequences
what I mean there adverse consequences to the evidence they need
to act there because there's reason to believe that's what's
going to >> I think it's insane to say that he is now destroying
evidence and then to arrest him for that. >> I think maybe
maybe you could stop him. Maybe you could justify stopping him
from manipulating the phone. I It's insane to arrest that guy
for trying to destroy evidence in that moment. >> What
is stopping him other than, you know, arresting him and grabbing
it for think he's going to destroy evidence. That's how you said
you could maybe grab the phone, but you don't arrest him for
destroying evidence from even touching the screen
him readjusting his hand. So, you're seizing an item without
a warrant, without a charge that you're suggesting is like you
probably >> If you're saying if you're saying that he's
seizing an item from him, then hold on. How could he have seized
the item from him without How could he have even taken it? >> What
do you mean he asked for it? He's asking the guy to comply. He's
asking the guy to hand over his evidence
>> He's saying, "I'm handing this over as evidence." And
then he starts doing,
>> you know, things that the officer can't officer He goes
he goes to move the >> You're saying yes. He goes he manipulates
the phone. He manipulates the phone suddenly as he's about to
>> handipulates the phone by putting his hands on the side
of the phone. >> No, by placing it in the officer's hand
at first and then yinking it away and then starting to press
buttons assumably. We can assume he's strong as well, but starting
to press buttons. At that point, yeah, I expect the officer to
act on >> you. You have no pretext for arresting somebody
for a crime. You go to talk to them. You convince them that they
have to give you something that they don't have the right to
as evidence. Then when you go to move that evidence, right? When
you go to like close that close your phone, you're going to arrest
them for destroying evidence. Evidence of what? You didn't even
know what was going on here.
You've like you've like somehow concocted a way to saying, "Is
this true? Are they are they seizing the phone?" All saying they
weren't seizing the phone at that point. They were just asked
him to comply.
But if they were seizing the phone, then 100% at that point they
they they should they're even more justified. >> I believe
they said they were seizing the phone pending a warrant.
Cops said >> If they were seizing the phone and were already
justified in seizing the phone and then he started acting like
that 100% they were justified in seizing it this and then that's
not even a question. It's not even debatable. >> Well,
that's what they said was they were seizing the phone like pending
a warrant to get the phone. >> Okay. Well, no,
they say that at what point in this?
They say, well, I believe they say that in their follow-up response.
That's what was happening >> Okay. Well, maybe we should
watch through the start of the body cam because I I watched this
on this earlier and I I didn't hear them say that they were seizing.
I thought he was being asked to hand over the option bases your
>> Yeah, for sure. >> No, go back. Go back. >> On
your phone and officer Richardson believes that you were facetiming
Ben while you were hanging a sign across from the guy's house
who Ben just got arrested for. We can appeal. We can we can request
a search warrant. >> Yeah. for your phone, which means
we seize your phone. >> Yeah, for sure. >> And if
we get into your phone and we find out that you were lying to
us, you can be arrested for this offense as >> Yeah, for
sure. >> That's a problem. However, if you cooperate with
us and you show us and you confirm that you're not involved and
this was all your idea. >> Yeah. So, he's being given an
option. He's not >> We probably
end up with your phone. >> Does that >> he's being
given this to show us and confirm that you're not involved with
all and this was all your idea. Yeah. then we probably end up
parting ways and you'll end up with your >> You understand
all of that? >> And sorry, it's not even that I believe
you were calling Ben. You also just told me that that was Ben.
So, >> yeah. Um, >> it's just suspicious to us and
because we think there's a law broken here, we're trying to get
to the bottle. >> Does that make sense? >> Okay.
Do you have any questions before >> say either basically
say we can do this the easy way or the hard way? They basically
say get a warrant, take your phone, or you can just give us your
phone. That's how they're presenting. >> Everything you
say can and will be used against you in a court of law with the
right to attorney if cannot afford.
>> Wait, is this after they take his phone from him? >> Thanks.
I know. No.
>> Attorney one will be provided for you if you decide
to answer questions now >> So they're arresting him. They're
mirandizing him right now, right? What are they mirandizing him
for? >> Attorney. Let's wind it back. We should wind it
back more. We should we should see more of this interaction.
This is useless without >> I don't think Do we have to
go all the way back to the beginning? Um
maybe put on like
permission and stuff. >> Yeah, we have permission from
this house. That orange house. >> Yeah, they were also
they thought we were good to go there too. So all of that property
is trying to get this gofund me going. It's legit gofund me.
>> What's what's it for? Sorry. >> We're giving back
uh this money for this family. Um let me pull up the Goofy. It's
a real It's a real GoFundMe. Um
>> it's real. Uh >> yeah. Do you want to hold this?
>> You want to hold it? >> Yeah, absolutely. >> Can
we say Simon? >> Uh oh [__] Oh, that's Ben,
right? >> Uh, yeah. >> Okay. Why'd you hang up so
fast? >> Oh, I don't He hadn't been on the phone >> That's
not true. >> I don't know if you saying verbally to the
cops, I'm like seizing I'm going to surrender this to you. I
don't know if that makes it surrendered to them. I don't even
know if touching it to his hand makes it surrendered to him.
>> No, I'm saying his I'm saying that his conduct there
>> gave reasonable suspicion that he was trying to uh destroy
evidence. I'm saying his conduct gave reasonable and at that
point I'm pretty sure they can arrest him and take his phone.
>> I totally disagree with that but keep >> But yeah
so here's the go. We got 10 bucks 28,000. That's okay. >> Can
I express some concern?
>> So I know who Ben is. I know the situation. I know the
situation with this guy the YouTube the Legos. I know all that.
Um he was right for stocking. Okay. Yeah. You know that. Um he's
paying you guys to be here. I know that too. Um he can't maybe
it' be better if he Yeah, I know he just left too. >> I
have no idea. >> Okay. The problem we're running into is
you guys are slowly becoming an accessory for stalking. So you
guys can be arrested for that. >> So we're kind of at the
phase point where the the people that are involved in this are
getting upset. We're here to keep the peace. We're here to make
sure that nobody gets in trouble, nobody gets hurt, nobody gets
arrested. But I don't think that this kind of stuff is going
to help the situation. >> Well, but if we get this off
and get the drone shot of it, it's going to look good and then
we'll take it all down and >> Yeah. That's how we're going
to we're going to cuz we can't, you know, we're not going to
do the the lawsuit anymore. We're just do the GoFundMe. We've
already got started. social issue that >> so already telling
on himself like crazy here. Like if they're already investigating
Ben for stalking and harassment and then this guy's basically
admitting to being involved and saying all this crazy [__]
that he's going to do, you're already telling yourself like [__]
crazy. Like shut the [__] up, you know, get a lawyer.
>> I like I understand that this might be the way Brits
look at this. I'm pretty sure Americans have like this insane
libertarian view of the world that like this isn't this guy's
property and he doesn't have the right to not be talked about
on this part of the world or in this part of the world that if
they get >> even in America you have to assert your rights.
Cops are going to try and investigate and you have to assert
your
>> You might have to assert your rights, but I'm saying
that I don't think there's I think the cops are just lying here,
right? >> Like clearly like I don't think you could be
arrested as an accessory for stalking for what they're currently
engaged in. Now, if they were talk about going to this guy's
property and with him, then maybe. But I don't think these people
can actually like be >> arrest
I don't know what the law is. I don't know what they've done
at this >> So, well, I'm telling you that from what I understand
in America like literally stalking requires you like going over
to their property and if they don't have a restraining order
and it's like basically the cops would have to tell that guy
file a restraining order.
>> Have they Have they filed the restraining order? Yeah.
At this point in the story, >> they must have at this point.
They must
>> They must have. There's a TTRO for Ben to not reference
them. I would imagine it like actually also enforces some sort
of perimeter that he could be in like stuff about filming them,
right? Like Ben literally can't talk about bricks and minifigs
at all anymore. So I'd imagine it also covers these guys,
>> right? Or maybe >> I just don't know what the
timeline I just don't know what the timeline is. I just don't
know whether TR is already filed at this point or or what.
I think they've trespassed
Ben from that property. And yeah, at this point I do believe
they've arrested him for stalking once and then he's gotten out.
>> Some definition stuff or it can have some other information
because the gentleman that officer Richardson is is explaining
has been arrested. He's not allowed to have contact with that
party or indirect contact either. >> Yeah. So you guys
are indirectly in contact with that party. So we don't want that
to threshold. Okay. Because that can mean you guys can get arrested
as well. >> I'm all for GoFundMe. I'm all for support.
I like what you guys are doing. None of my business. But you
have to understand we're not stupid either. I know you're FaceTiming
Ben. I know he's having you do this and cool. If that's what
he's doing, then cool. But I'm just I guess this is >> like
he explained, you don't want to be caught up in this. Ben doesn't
want to go to jail again. We don't want to arrest him again.
Like that's not what we want to do. Obviously, we have to do
our job. I know you guys are doing >> what we want is not
take people to jail. We want we want Ben and his posy, whatever
you guys call yourselves, reckless Ben, whatever. We want you
guys to be happy. We don't care, but [snorts] we also have to
look out for them. >> I'm going to double check with the
neighbors, make sure it's cool, you use their fence. I believe
you. But, you know, seems like I'm also This is really the most
publicity. This this fence on on stores a is the best publicity.
>> This drone it's going to be the best drone angle. We
we hired a drone scientist and he said this was a really good
spot. >> So I mean we you know we invest a lot in this
GoFundM already and I think it's going to be >> Yeah, this
guy's an huge you guys are aware we we also may have uh city
ordinance regarding hosting signage. So we're going to look into
that before we leave. Um I realize that this is on private property
but it is on the sidewalk. So yeah, >> not to not to hustle
you guys too much, but yeah. No, you're fine. We got to make sure
that a no laws are being broken and b nobody's going to be injured
or trouble. >> Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. Maybe give
officer Richardson a moment. Check with the owner of the fence.
Hang out with us. Let them know. >> Can you address and
these people are coming? Can you go over there? >> No.
One sec. >> You know, I don't think
>> Get out of here. Get out of here. Get out of here. Get
out of here. >> This is a woman conspiracy.
>> Explain about um who found me. So, I just said, >> "Yeah,
I just check it's up it's up to you. Um they just said they have
your permission. I just checked with you and it sounds like they
do have your permission." Cool. Thank you. >> Hey, is he
nice? >> Hi, puppy. >> Okay. I don't know what's
going on. >> Thank you. >> I appreciate it. If he
comes over to your house like that again, call us. >> Yeah.
So, they're not fans of that guy either. They're not big fans
of the Brandon guy, obviously.
>> Crab merchant. Shut the [__] up. Doesn't
work. Don't talk to the police. Doesn't work. When you are the
victim reporting on someone else, who do you think is the victim
in this story?